dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonah feher
approximately seven months ago we
discussed an ai-based technique
called stylegan 2 which could synthesize
images of human faces for us
as a result none of the faces that you
see here are real
all of them were generated by this
technique the quality of the images and
the amount of detail they're in
is truly stunning we could also exert
artistic control
over these outputs by combining aspects
of multiple faces together
and as the quality of these images
improve over time
we think more and more about new
questions to ask about them
and one of those questions is for
instance how original
are the outputs of these neural networks
can these really make
something truly unique and believe it or
not
this paper gives us a fairly good answer
to that
one of the key ideas in this work is
that in order to change the outputs we
have to change the model
itself now that sounds a little nebulous
so let's have a look at an example
first we choose a rule that we wish to
change in our case
this will be the towers we can ask the
algorithm to show us matches to this
concept
and indeed it highlights the towers on
the images we haven't marred up yet
so it indeed understands what we meant
then we highlight the tree as a goal
place it accordingly onto the water
and a few seconds later
there we go the model has been
reprogrammed such that instead of towers
it would make trees something original
has emerged here
and look not only on one image but on
multiple images
at the same time now have a look at
these human faces
by the way none of them are real and
we're all synthesized by stargand 2
the method you saw at the start of the
video some of them do not appear to be
too happy about the research progress in
machine learning
but i am sure that this paper can put a
smile on their faces
let's select the ones that aren't too
happy then
copy a big smile and paste it onto their
faces
see if it works
it does wow let's flick between the
before
and after images and see how well the
changes are adapted
to each of the target faces truly
excellent work
and now on to eyebrows hold on to your
papers while we choose a few of them
and now i hope you agree that this
mustache would make a glorious
replacement for them
and there we go
perfect and note that with this we are
violating betterage's law of headlines
again
in this series because the answer to our
central question
is a resounding yes these neural
networks can indeed create
truly original works and what's more
even entire data sets that haven't
existed before
now at the start of the video we noted
that instead of editing images
it edits the neural network's model
instead
if you look here we have a set of input
images created by a generator network
then as we highlight concepts for
instance the watermark text here
we can look for the weights that contain
this information and rewrite
the network to accommodate these user
requests in this case
to remove these patterns now that they
are gone
by selecting humans we can again rewrite
the network weights
to add more of them
and finally the signature tree trick
from earlier can take place
the key here is that if we change one
image
then we have a new and original image
but if we change the generator model
itself we can make thousands of new
images
in one go or even a full data set
loving the idea and perhaps the
trickiest part of this work
is minimizing the effect on other
weights while we reprogram the ones we
wish to change
of course there will always be some
collateral damage
but the results in most cases still seem
to remain
intact make sure to have a look at the
paper to see how it's done exactly
also good news the authors also provided
an online notebook
where you can try this technique
yourself if you do
make sure to read the instructions
carefully and regardless of whether you
get successes or failure cases
make sure to post them in the comments
section here in research
both are useful information so after the
training step has taken place
neural networks can be rewired to make
sure they create
truly original works and all this on not
one image
but on a mass scale what a time to be
alive
but you see here is an instrumentation
of this exact paper we have talked about
which was made
by weights and biases weights and biases
provides tools to track your experiments
in your deep learning projects their
system is designed to save you a ton of
time and money
and it is actively used in projects at
prestigious labs
such as open ai toyota research github
and more and the best part is that if
you have an open source
academic or personal project you can use
their tools for free
it really is as good as it gets make
sure to visit them through wnb.com
papers or click the link in the video
description
to start tracking your experiments in
five minutes
our thanks to weights and biases for
their long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i'll see you next time